so uh you haven't told anybody really
oh no no not publicly no i haven't shot
in
i have not shot uh heels in exactly
three weeks today i head back to work
tomorrow i tested positive for covet 19
uh cheese
15 days ago two weeks ago monday
um today being i think this is airing
next week but today being
tuesday october is it today
october the 20th so maybe 15 15 days ago
and yeah and the thing is is that i
um had already been
um i had already been isolated from work
because uh there was um there was a
positive test
on the show and i i repeatedly tested
negative uh
through the week um but
but ultimately for whatever reason came
down with symptoms the following monday
got tested on the tuesday
and um i've actually been clear to go
back to work since friday
this past friday but they didn't know if
i would be cleared
for sure until basically this wednesday
so they have been building other stuff
into the schedule so as a lead actor
you're getting tested on set every day
or every they check well they check your
temperature i believe every day right
when you arrive on set every day you
have your temperature taken
you can't just even if you're at the
studio obviously when you drive into the
studio get your temperature taken
um they scan your card you have to have
filled out
a wellness report um you know
have you had a fever do you have any of
the following symptoms have you had
exposure you had
and then you have your temperature taken
um and
even when you know you're arriving at
you're arriving at base camp or
something like that when you're on
location
someone's there to take your temperature
um um
this is all being done by a company out
of arkansas called cteh
i think they're working actually on a
number a number of shows not just ours
and they're excellent they're excellent
at uh
they're excellent at what they do did
you have a fever one day or
or were you already experiencing
something maybe the day before you're
like
ah [ __ ] i woke up
and it was the strangest thing
[ __ ] right ear was plugged
and i was hot and cold
i never ran a fever um
it i'd say that that
i noticed something i i started to
notice something on a monday but
didn't have a didn't have a test result
phoned up the people at ctah had them
come to my apartment test me
came back positive the following
wednesday got tested again
came back positive again but frankly at
that point
i didn't need a second positive test
because those first couple of days just
really they they just they just sucked
um sucked how i compared to like how you
felt
okay so this is interesting um
for two nights i was up
every couple of hours vacillating
between freezing cold
and boiling hot and i'd be freezing cold
because i would sweat
through all my stuff but get up
dry off change my clothes
um get back into bed warm up
and then start sweating again and just
like the cycle would just
the cycle would just the cycle would
just repeat um
and the biggest thing and really i felt
maybe the onset
of a symptom or two on a monday and then
by friday i was feeling great but that
that tuesday
that tuesday wednesday i felt very
very much like i was in a fog
you